forgive me ma'am but very few hundred
company ladies travel beyond no more
then they are missing some rare beauty
you're not a soldier's wife no I'm a
painter affair yes no no none amenity
presumptious but you did that certainly
look is that look at someone filled with
good intentions
Weston Missouri can be lethal she came
all the way from New York to paint India
I'm going to paint the Great Sioux chief
Sitting Bull that a fact
oh I have traveled many miles from the
east across many rivers and Hills for
the honor of speaking with you
you got a train from New York right yes
thanks you're not good at keeping still
are you shoot me then I will be still
what would be the point of shooting you
bullets don't seem to have any effect
this is what's my vision my soldiers
thought in the sky Custer with his army
they tracked down every chief kill them
all
except for you the only battle ever
fought against his insignificance Olivia
this river do not give him reason out no
one here is for you I've never forgiven
least of all yourself in Calgary let's
head over now sitting both dead you'll
think that you and me up letting some
kind of uprising the people need a sign
for them to believe in their own
strength
they've been angry for a long time our
fear that is returned to the code is
about revenge
you idiots in Washington want to start
another war
free free don't mess across off this was
the general wanted all along to deep
then that's what the bull wants to know
terrible things have happened here in
the past unjust you to paint painting
you